hello everybody Merry Christmas Happy
Holidays are happy whatever you
celebrate in December I hope it's a good
one I just wanted to make a quick video
to say thank you guys so much again I
know I say thank you pretty much every
one of these vlogs but you know I wanted
to look back on the year that's come
because it's been one of the most
amazing whirlwind fantastic whatever
adjective you want to use year that I've
ever had in my entire life because last
year sometimes late November I hit a
million subscribers and I was totally
taken aback by this because I didn't
think that I would get to a million let
alone get to a million that quickly so
when it happened
I created this other lofty goal of
hitting 5 million subscribers in a
year's time and what's even more amazing
is that I was only off by a month
because right now we're on track to hit
5 million subscribers exactly on
Christmas Day which is astonishing and
confusing but it's really amazing to see
so much come out of this weird year
where I've transitioned from Cincinnati
leaving my friends and family to meeting
so many cool youtubers and getting these
opportunities to literally travel the
world and meet you guys and celebrate
what we've done in this community and to
cap off this year I want to make sure
that I understand exactly why I did this
and what my reasons for being here are
and to start it off and there's going to
be a lot more things I've worked out a
few deals here and there that you're
gonna find out in the next few days or
weeks where I'm gonna be able to give
back a lot more but to start it off I am
going I'm Justin telling you guys that
when I go back to Cincinnati for
Christmas I'm going to be donating ten
thousand dollars to the Cincinnati
Children's Hospital because Cincinnati
is where this all started it's where
markiplier started it's where all my
family is and where all my friends are
and Cincinnati Children's Hospital
actually saved one of my friend's life
Tyler shied he had a kidney transplant
where his brother donated him a kidney
he was on a charity livestream a long
time ago you may heard some of you may
or may not know him but he's a really
cool guy he's also moderated a couple
live streams of mine and I just wanted
to start this
into the year off right by giving back
because it's been so good to me this
year has been so amazing to me I've had
not only so many experiences but the
privilege of being able to play video
games for you guys for a living is just
astonishing and I only have you guys to
thank for it so sincerely thank you guys
for having my back and supporting me
this whole time
and giving me these opportunities which
is really something special that I can
never you know ignore or take advantage
of so sincerely thank you guys so much
and you'll see more coming in the next
few days because my schedule is so busy
I'm really hoping that I'll be able to
do a charity livestream it may not be 12
hours but I'm gonna try to do something
before the end of the month on top of
everything else that I planned so just
thank you guys so much for your support
unending unwavering support it's
phenomenal and you guys should be as
proud of yourselves as I am of you for
what you've managed to do in this
community and also uh there's one more
thing before I wanted to go this new
video came out over on synodos channel
it's with me in a suit Dani sex bang
Matthias and cyndago we're all together
it's this really hilarious game show if
it doesn't make sense to you it's
talking about how weird the job market
is and how arbitrary it's a higher
concept that kind of is lost on the joke
it's hilarious they did so much work on
it it was back when my hair was shorter
and I need a haircut but if you want to
see it's been floating up here click on
it I highly recommend it
you will get a laugh out of it I
guarantee it and if you don't too bad
its Julie you already watched it so
seriously thank you guys so much for
watching I hope to do more stuff like
this in the future because cyndago is
coming to LA and we're going to be able
to make videos and cool stuff I have a
lot planned it's going to be a great
year tomorrow
tomorrow it's gonna be a great year next
year man but I just can't wait this year
has been so good I cannot wait to see
what next year is gonna be like so thank
you all so much for watching thank you
all so much for your support and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye-bye